the Metal Gear series has always
delivered complex plots with unexpected
twists and revelations altering your
perception of people and events you
thought you understood the middle Gear
Solid 5 the phantom pain continues this
tradition the majority of its plot
focuses on the events at hand fans of
the series will find their diligence
rewarded in ways that newcomers can't
begin to imagine but such loyalty and
knowledge isn't a prerequisite as big
boss the leader of a private military
group that Diamond Dogs you go behind
enemy lines to carry out recon and
assassination contracts as well as
infiltrate the hideouts of your personal
enemies The Phantom Pain's plot mixes
historical events from the 1980s with a
pinch of James Bond villainy in an
exciting dollop of sci-fi dressing
your mission is twofold build a military
force free from the whims of
narrow-minded world powers and destroy
those who wish to take advantage of
fractured global politics for their own
selfish ideals
there are numerous subplots within and
during your long and extensive journey
you face topics rarely seen in gaming
torture child soldiers and a human cost
of nuclear proliferation
the phantom pain depicts these issues
with unveiled brutality reminding you
that any order we know today came at the
cost of somebody else's freedom and
happiness the prologue middle Gear Solid
5 Ground zeroes gave us a taste of the
series new open-world mechanics which
feel is excellent now as they did in
that game but the freedom of choice in
ground zeroes pales in comparison to the
possibilities that await you in the
phantom pain you don't always have to
sneak in some cases you must attack
head-on both types of scenarios and
still a nerve-racking sense of tension
that either gives way to crushing defeat
or a resounding sense of victory success
isn't just measured by getting from
point A to point B or by defeating a
notorious bad guy remember you're trying
to build a private army while convincing
enemy troops to join your ranks would
require expert coercion in the real
world in the phantom pain you simply
attach a balloon to your friends waist
and they float into the arms of an
awaiting chopper
of course dead soldiers aren't good to
anybody so you're motivated to tread
carefully and quietly to incapacitate
your enemies without raising alarm in
order to capture your prey a lot all of
your hard work capturing soldiers in
addition to resources wildlife and
vehicles pays off back at mother base
your offshore sanctum here soldiers
you've captured can be assigned to
different research fields once your team
hits certain levels and you possess the
right amount of materials that you
source from the field you then earn the
right to develop new equipment there are
dozens of items and pieces of equipment
to unlock and you may spend upwards of a
hundred hours searching for top-notch
recruits and gathering resources while
infiltrating enemy bases if you hope to
unlock everything in the game while
visiting mother base staring out over
the ocean gives you a moment of solace
from the horrible events that surround
you on the battlefield and you get a
similar feeling when riding into battle
seated on the edge of a chopper
reflecting on the meaning behind the
madness at hand the open world is
replete with small military outposts
massive compounds and threats from
nature all opportunities for action and
reward an outpost may contain a vehicle
worth stealing or a soldier that will
provide useful information if you can
quietly detain interrogated unlike
previous Metal Gear games many which
place players in enclosed spaces a
threat can come from miles away and
appear next to you when you least expect
it nothing is confined and no place is
safe you eventually earn the right to
call in a transport via a horse a truck
or even a small robotic walker which is
as charming and expressive as r2d2 from
Star Wars if you play your cards right
you can also take a dog into battle that
will sniff out and distract enemies the
new open-world on the buddy system add
layers of depth that ultimately set the
fan of pain apart from other games in
the series
the story's final strokes cast deep dark
shadows over the world for anyone just
joining the tale of big boss with the
phantom pain the conclusion of these
events will leave you with plenty to
think about everything is questionable
and nothing is as it seems
for fans of the series the ultimate
payoff is one that answers questions but
also one that raises unforeseen
implications unfortunately in the
lead-up to the finale you have to spend
an hour or two replaying older missions
on a higher difficulty setting just to
unlock the final story missions this is
the only aspect of the phantom pain that
feels off ultimately the game delivers
an impactful finale befitting the
journey that preceded it it punches you
in the gut and tears your heart open the
high caliber cutscenes filled with
breathtaking shots and rousing speeches
tease you along the way the story is
dished out in morsels so you'll have to
work for the full meal but it's hard to
call it work when controlling big boss
feels so good with so many possibilities
at your fingertips there has never been
a Metal Gear game with such depth to its
gameplay or so much volume in content
when it comes to storytelling there has
never been a game in this series that's
so consistent in tone daring in subject
matter and so captivating in this
presentation
the phantom pain may be a contender for
one of the best action games ever made
it is undoubtedly the best Metal Gear
game there is for more details on what
you can find in the phantom pain and how
I feel about them check out the full
written review on GameSpot calm
don't even mess it up to you boss make
your way to - uh Google a running to
target
Roger that
we'll pick him up